yes i did
okay
well we can talk about that later then
okay you are never gonna believe this
the girl in the video we're watching the
corporate gave us daryl banged her
and he's about 90 sure
don't ever let this little [ __ ] drive
you around town we got lost for a half
an hour i don't have any dui so i can
drive myself but thanks
where is michael snot sniffing some
dude's thong
probably
so you are the lawyer mr o'malley i know
a lot of lawyer jokes i love lawyer
jokes well it's probably because you
don't get them
when i said before that i was king of
forwards you got to understand that i
don't come up with this stuff i just
forward it along
you wouldn't arrest a guy who's just
delivering drugs from one guy to
another you seem a little bit agitated
michael what's the problem the problem
is that
i am the boss and apparently i can't say
anything
well that that's my that's true in a way
you can't say anything
where's the line where's the line jan do
you need to see the video again michael
i've seen the video he talked the whole
time no it didn't
what
attention everyone hello
uh yes i just want you to know that uh
this is not my decision but from here on
out we can no longer be friends
and when we talk about things here we
must only discuss uh work-associated
things
and uh you can consider this my
retirement from comedy
and in the future if i want to say
something funny or witty or do an
impression i will no longer
ever do any of those things
does that include
that's what she said
yes wow that is really hard
you really think you can go all day long
well
you always left me satisfied and smiling
so
that's what she said
michael please seriously
did you have time to think about my
offer i did have a chance to think about
it but then i thought about something
else so which way
well it is tempting but i am 100 leaning
towards passing that's true hey did
anyone see the client list that michael
was supposed to be working on
no okay let me know if you find it
hey
don't look at me people stop don't look
down don't look down he's gonna see me
not all the way up keep him at a normal
height okay this is not michael scott
talking right now this is your future
hello
i am your future
you are older and you are very happy now
because you went with michael scott
right
so everybody come on down
now let's just crawl out of here
together
all right
come on
are you are you doing your best here
are you being the best that you can be
all right everybody
who's gonna go with me i want you to
stomp your foot
okay
all right
come on
come on
you're coming with me
come on fellas
here we go
here we go
michael get oh god okay all right all
right time to go time to go jam let's go
come on come on michael what are you
doing i think maybe hank should be here
hank
no i don't need him
you're gonna mess with me is that what
you're gonna do i'll tell you something
charles i don't even care
because i've got nothing to lose
oh my god oh god no no all right
it's not worth it
um all right well then
i will proceed i just have some
questions that i was gonna ask
um
who do you think you are
toby
yeah
correct
um
what gives what
what gives you the right
um i i brought the binder do you wanna
take a little look sure you know what
that sounds good i'll take a little
look-see
here we go thank you
what
would you improve
about
no i'm not asking it i'm just reading it
out loud oh i'd like to hear the answer
well let me see i would um
i guess everything's okay
i made it this far right
what's the point
toby why don't you open your present no
no no no no no no no this hey hey hey
hey this might not be what i think
that i don't even know is in there
because there are a lot of presents in
my car and i don't know which is which
suck on this
what the hell is that michael that's
what do you mean michael
that's not even my handwriting hey
what the hell is going on here
who thought it would be hysterical to
give toby a rock
for his going away gift you did no you
made me wrap it no i thought it was over
the line
okay you know what that is you know what
that is that is
a psych
psych
so that is not my real gift to toby so
what is your gift my gift is forthcoming
pam
what is it
i am going to give
toby
your watch
yes i am
that was it
how did you know that i just knew how
did you know oh that is so sweet well
that's my watch thanks i'm gonna set it
to costa rica time hey that's good
look who i found yeah well i was very
hard to find
let's go ahead and wash your hands
is this the same dough that you use for
the pizza crust yeah waste not right so
these are pizza dogs these aren't pigs
in a blanket per se
michael knows everything there is to
know about snacks well
gabe was born in 1982. he was the
longest baby in the hospital he's the
longest baby in this room what's the
longest thing you've ever seen
for me it was the tail from a jet aaron
you don't have to yeah you know what
erin you do after michael
you were making this harder than it has
to be that's what she said
great i'm in
i guess you guys working saturday
your face
no no i'm i'm not coming in on saturday
yeah this isn't happening
uh
well guys
you know
i am the boss so yeah
so what what's that we we coming in on
monday right
monday
you guys believe me
come
on
you know you should know me better than
that
no oh do you think that would have been
good for morale no
no no exactly no i'm i'm embarrassed it
was even that close so now of course
we're coming in saturday
good game yeah word
[Applause]
you